so you probably read the title and
thought this was cook bait but I assure
you it's definitely not click bait not
only do players of for honor have to
deal with the light attack spam of
peacekeeper that unblock the unpunished
herbal kick of shinobi the croc control
of Centurion we now have to deal with
wardens one-shot kill ability basically
this started around nine hours ago
roughly for my time and I guess on
reddit there was a video of a Centurion
fighting a warden decentering
ends up getting parried and then he got
one shot so I decided to try to recreate
it and there was even steps in the right
opposed to do this basically you just
have to guard break the guy out of
stance and then press the guard stance
button and the heavy tag button at the
same exact time and it will cause the
game to believe that you are doing a
plunging attack but except from instead
of 30 feet off the bridge of overwatch
it's the two inches off the floor so the
game and if everybody if anybody knows
if you've played obviously for honor for
a few days you've obviously figured out
that plunging attacks will one-shot you
regardless of your health regardless of
their health or anything it will always
one shot you so this is what I'm
believing is that it's making the game
acted as if it's a plunging attack so
that's why everyone's getting one
shotted so when I was recreating this I
noticed that it was super simple and
really easy to pull off but then I
figured out well if it's only starting
from a guard break all you have to do is
just knock it guard broken and then I
forgot who I was playing as and then I
realized that it's warden any of you who
have never played warden before or at
all even noticed you may have noticed
that warden has a shoulder bash type of
move where he presses the dash button
with the X button and he can pull a
shoulder bash unblockable move for
anybody that's played enough you know
that it's a 50/50 to where that he can
hit you or he can cancel it into a guard
break I ended up recreating this in a
game against the bots and I was able to
cancel the guard break get out of guard
stance mode and pull off the unshot kill
so this can happen without the shoulder
bash and with the shoulder - I decided
to scurry around some of the comments of
that exact post and I noticed that a
a couple of people have mentioned that
they were able to pull it off as a
Centurion and a shinobi and they're also
able to pull it off with no bushi and
Orochi but you had to be out of stamina
to do it I wasn't able to recreate these
I've been doing this for the past twenty
to thirty minutes trying to figure this
out and I've yet to make the other care
the other four characters work I've
noticed that it's only with warden
Ubisoft needs to take act as well
blizzard did about a month or two ago
with diva diva is one of the characters
in their new game overwatch is none of
you have played it and there was a very
there was something game breaking with
her or something happened where they had
to disable her for a couple days to fix
her and then put her back in the game so
I believe Ubisoft should do this exact
same thing warden take him out for a few
days catch them and then put them back
in but knowing Ubisoft their patches are
going to roll out two weeks from now and
they're not going to disable him and
we're going to have to do with wardens
one-shotting us for the next two weeks
anyway that's really all I have to say
about this video this is really not much
else to say this is definitely a
plunging attack but the game is making
it as if it's a plunging attack but it's
really not your own you're still on even
ground and this is probably going to be
happening with a lot of warden
characters in the next couple days so if
you're ever wondering why you've been
one shotted it's because of this anyway
I hope you all did enjoyed this video
I'm doing this to raise to spread the
awareness of this glitch so that Ubisoft
understands it is a very problem they
need to fix it immediately but anyway if
you want to see if you want to see more
of me subscribe if you're new if you
like the video like that hit that like
button and if you want to see my
previous upload if you missed it click
the top right car or cook the card in
the top right we talked about the
devastating recap with the quitter
penalty being announced and then a
colorblind mode with some ranked mode
coming soon anyway guys that would be
the end of the video today if you all
did enjoy a thank you for that and I
will see you all later peace out